[Music]
mr. Martin you have no idea what you
have unleashed
she'sa like anything we've ever faced
welcome to pro did you
[Applause]
my character Nick he's just caught up in
this whole world that he doesn't want to
get caught up in who are you I'm a
doctor
Milan is Jekyll dr. Henry Jekyll
the central character behind all the
events of the movie is dr. Henry Jekyll
famous for being Jekyll and Hyde dr.
Jekyll operates a thing called idiom and
pretty Geum essentially is an
organization that in points evil and
tries to neutralize it leaking eyes
examine contain destroy people they
study the mythologies and monsters the
histories of them
princess ha Manette she's selected you
was the vessel for the ultimate evil
it's a science for them and what I liked
about that idea was if we're gonna
ground the monsters in a reality then
let's ground it in science
we like the idea that / Digium was
hiding in plain sight in the Natural
History Museum and that Jekyll could use
the resources of the museum to further
his own research into monsters was a lot
to find out with Jacqueline
it's not giving too much away to say
that he has quite a clear understanding
of evil it takes a monster to defeat a
monster
I love the element of mystery it's quite
dangerous and exciting that's not to be
wary from their likeness
welcome to a new world of gods and
monsters
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
whatever than their cuz them safely
hidden for 2,000 years
this isn't a tomb
it's a prison Nick
the hieroglyphs said she was named
Arnett chosen to be Egypt's next queen
but her thirst for power led her down a
darker path one that had to be stopped
because of your actions
this ancient power has returned
[Music]
you are alive because you were chosen
sure but what evil
the ultimate evil
legend has it she's a being of
unimaginable power now she's using him
to regain them
she will not stop until she has we made
our world
[Music]
into her own
[Music]
stay with me is good way to figure this
out
you can't run you can't escape
she's got plans for you
[Music]
mmm